قال المؤنسات الغاليه تداول رواد مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي مشهدا لطفله مغربيه
ظهرت في وهي تواسي والدها بعد خساره منتخب
المغرب ضد فرنسا في كاس العالم الرواد
اشاد بتعامل الطفله وعاطفتها التي طالت
على المشهد بينما لم يتجاوز عمرها 10
اعوام
[موسيقى]
شرطيه هندي
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تظهر الضابطه
الهنديه وهو يتشابك مع رجال شرطه اخرين
حاولوا فتحه فمه لاثبات تلقيه رشوه وذلك
بعد ما قام باكل سته الاف روبيه اي ما
يعادل 70 دولار الشرطه الهنديه فتحت
تحقيقا في الواقعه الا انها لم تتمكن من
اخراج الاموال والسبب ان الضابط قام
ببلعها كامله
[موسيقى]
تقدمت والده الطفله المغربيه التي سخرت من
خروج كريستيانو رونالدو من كاس العالم
بالاعتذار لجميع عشاق رونالدو وكره القدم
وذلك بعد التنمر الكبير على ابنتها التي
تبلغ من العمر تسعه اعوام فقط الام قالت
ان ابنتها تعاني من حاله النفسيه وترفض
الاكل بسبب التنمر عليها في مواقع التواصل
وايضا من صديقاتها وتطلب التوقف من عن نشر
صورها القصه تعود لفيديو انتشر منذ ايام
لفتاه مغربيه وهي تسخر من رونالدو عاقبه
فوز المنتخب المغربي على نظيره البرتغالي
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم